[Music]
you say yeah you know I've been watching
yourself but I find that the youngsters
here they cannot come and debate here
they have no knowledge let me have
knowledge of the Quran yeah but they're
not have knowledge of the Bible or the
Torah so when the Christians or the
others you know speakers come here
that's not all these things at them when
they go oh I have no where you in turn
say hold on hold on one second and you
take a step back well you might skip to
say this what about you scriptures they
say this and then they have no answer to
this very very forceful I'm thinking the
Dhamma should be done in a practical way
in a humble way so it comes across but
when I realize some of the brothers here
or the other speakers here how they are
very very rude and arrogant I think
maybe you have to take the same approach
to them unless the only way you come
across to them like if you can talk loud
I can talk louder sometimes you have to
do this you know but I mean we need to
come down here because I might have a B
that will not be able to come here but I
made an especial effort I came here
hafez 10:00 this morning
and they said they don't start till
11:00 o'clock oh we went round and look
around everything else in it's got busy
now but I didn't realize you know come
here about three o'clock afternoon so I
should you debating with the other
brothers I couldn't make out what he was
saying about the hand and I think I'm
just going to extreme here but you made
a very very good point about you know
the [ __ ] has a hand and the door handle
at the hand I mean it literally has a
hand it's a figure of speech
normal accord is running towards you
literally running toward you it's a
figure of speech
and plus it's it's a wave for the
numerous understand you know because
allies we can imagine because it's
nothing like you know explains things
but we can understand if there is life
something was in French you read and you
say but what the brother was trying to
just nitpick and go to extreme compare
it to the real like you know saying oh
that means over half limbs so there's
certain attribute indicates a la ya but
ya know like my first in life may Allah
bless you for coming because that
mashallah you know I'm gonna you know
you're a user well etc so it's an honor
for us to have you to come here
mashallah to just even show you support
so that's why you came Amal I mean it's
not for us because and then they
sometimes that you said before I've even
in the park here today that I think he
has some people are again some people
are harsh but sometimes we shouldn't
talk to their level yes sometimes we can
be firm can be further even if
somebody's you know insulting the
Prophet said I would say don't talk to
this person you can be firm but
sometimes a lot people go down the
memory of arrogance you know and
thinking that you're better and this
attitude we don't know that's the reason
why we started this and I'm gonna
because you're gonna have nice
discussions supervised discussion
no shelter no ego no I'm better than you
your your you know your your misguided
your their show that have that but who
so what I found important act therefore
ones talk to you on food is that you
want to your body okay may Allah bless
refers the Africa coming Alana do you
think today our youngsters they respect
to lose their elders
what do you think yeah but then it's not
the same for everybody
it depends on our elders do we respect
our children going into a mosque when
we're sitting down the mosque and you
have children coming down yeah you know
and the father brings the children
everything else and they run around they
see an old man like me sitting there
and they come up to me you say Salam
alaikum I say welcome Salam this is not
the way to do it the child goes I'm not
going there anymore but the child come
in the mosque he says so many things a
while comes along better how are you
when you have some sweets in there again
you do get around to go back so it's our
parents our elders did you teach our
children how to behave how to respect
their elders and the same time the
elders should respect the children as
well not just say oh I'm older I have
appeared I'm more knowledgeable they
knew that you don't know nothing this is
the wrong attitude is no but Islam
teaches us to live if you are only
higher in God's eyes if you have taqwa
not because I have more white beard than
you that I know more knowledge no
because you have no knowledge of me
practice fact you have Monalisa
she's more height than me in the eyes of
Allah Allah we don't know you baby maybe
one deed you did is better than
everything I did because in my but the
fact remains of the knowledge that I
have
oh yeah in the eyes of Allah subhanAllah
you have more knowledge to use more than
me that's what I'm trying to say to you
maybe I have more but yeah you doing a
great great job and you raised a very
very vital point so cuz that today I was
talking about for example that I said
how to respect your elders but that's
actually very beautiful what you said
that you said you know hold on a second
as elders do we have respect towards our
tree our young as well because sometimes
when young kids come to the Masjid don't
shout don't and the person Selim didn't
have this attitude you know because why
because sadly I love our elder uncle's
me on a blessing ma'sha'allah sometimes
they make hard pins hearts to their
children and and the perspective value
came from was absolutely brilliant it
was very beautiful because I do believe
I love youngsters they do not have as
much respect for the O's in today's time
but also well surprise first as well
that it is to working more praise each
other so for me it's like you know that
I believe that we should always respect
our elders you know whatever it may be
like I was reading an ad about my friend
he talks about a cloud the man is more
fighting if I remember sending one of
the second books that amazed if I'm not
mistaken and he says that for example
your father you know you should never
walk in front of your father you should
never call your father by his name you
do not sit down before your father sits
down these are basic other manners now
one should have with his father you know
and I think that respect has been lost
and we need to regain that both from the
young person to their uncle or the
auntie or vice versa
is very important because otherwise
subhanallah wa live at times where
there's people taking and putting their
parents in care homes and what lie today
they will study shows that nine
million elderly people unknown me they
are depressed and that is so sad you
know because and it's a massive sin if
I'm not mistaken is this mentioned a
hadith that you know the man who Janna
don't take doesn't take care of his
parents you looked after him and just
put him in a care home why because he's
too busy and my it's a very sad state
that we live in so yeah I just want to
share there's anything else you have
time ago reminder to you you made a good
suggestion that you said you know like I
came in I shook your hands everybody has
nice to meet you and you guided me here
let's have a little chitchat you know on
the open in the chair but your parents
are booty dictator like your elders and
I said you know I don't want to sit down
yes I want to you know and this is what
we have to get across into the media
will be brothers and sisters here that
sit down Pope
yes you must talk to each other with
humbleness understand them guide them
exactly they can guide them tell them
look this is the truth what do you
accept you don't accept yet we need to
if we do our bit a bit of Dawa our
parents are watching to make easy on to
their children as well because when it
comes to like marriage and stuff like
this
there is not another connection and it's
very sad because when the children don't
find that connection they go down the
wrong route wrong path it's very
important for the daughter or the son to
have a good relation with a parent that
they can turn to you speeds because if
they are going to talk to you and if you
shun them away they're gonna go and talk
to their bad friends so in college
there's parents watching his uncle what
advice would you give them
well glad you mentioned that because to
my son-in-law is here with me you say
he's definitely said I want to marry him
no if I said to her what do you mean you
want to marry me the boy can't hear the
boy speak he has no house he has no
money no
coño job how can you marry somebody like
that but you know as they say first of
all you don't look at how hiiis
fair-skinned
what's the money cars bungalows he'll
eat faster animals whatever yes he's no
more drinking no bismillah the car
myself I'm cool I can I can I kiss you
for it well I hate you
may Allah bless you what you said one
lie it's absolutely profound what you
send that one by you to stop you cut you
off there again and then people be good
in the car we have got to go to the
movie you're gonna go to the Imam he
will make war and he would do this and
then the sermon will be complete no
every father shoots marry his daughter a
son is very very super good Monica but
because we don't have knowledge simple
knowledge simple knowledge how to do the
car even have to read them us how to
lead them Imams have to do general that
these are basic things that all Muslims
is know well stand behind a mom and let
him do it everything is not these
responsibilities it is your
responsibility as as well so my daughter
is all along their land and other things
really then you get your goat this man
do I have food or 2010 lapis and for my
son you know they are much like very
very good people get married to
limousines helicopters I don't wish the
money and then send him to Hollywood
Bollywood I send my daughters to say
money I've gone to Hajj I do my first
finish now it's up to that and this is
the Islamic way of doing it it's the
easiest way and simple way marketing
this
I mean while you gave something
beautiful that's the reason why I wanted
to call you here because I could see
when you know you came and spoke to me
you know beautiful advice and Charlotte
may Allah bless you and you know there's
a heavy for the process said and he said
that if a righteous man comes to ask you
do this hand if you reject them they'll
be fitting in the land you know and this
is what we have in Charlotte for our
parents are watching this please
inshallah Michelle inshallah make it
easy for your children may Allah bless
you I'm cool well I was a pleasure to
Allah and we've got a son in Norway a
son-in-law
where's that man and now I'm trying to
be on camera or no camera come on you
see see now see that's it I'm here yeah
uncle you sit come sit down
no you see ya see ya yeah cuz I mean
I've been I just do this yeah so because
so can Izzy can he communicate can he
hear us or not yeah tell him I love him
for the sake of Allah
is there anything he will maybe you
would want to tell me
tell him does he love me love me we are
a bless you guys barman sister it's
absolutely beautiful we had a beautiful
uncle here beautiful son-in-law in sha
Allah may Allah bless them and this is
the spirit that we should have you no
respect to our elders having discussions
and a beautiful role model that when a
person who's Wally I wouldn't even call
him disabled I called I called the one
who I believe who's disabled is the one
who doesn't follow the Quran and Sunnah
so why we are disabled Bravo who came
you up we couldn't walk and he was
looking to get married and he went for
long struggles and he said he wanted to
marry a sister and they would say all
about your disabled I said well I I
believed a with the same here the head
node see this because he come here you
can speak doesn't mean he's not there
you had more knowledge than me
disability people who read the Quran I
don't follow the Quran I think the other
people exactly you can you can have all
the limbs not working but somebody who
has in limbs working might be more
disabled than you in the heart and
that's what we need to understand each
other from the sisters may Allah bless
you guys it was actually absolutely
beautiful one of the most beautiful
discussions I've had in this park for a
long time
Salaam alaikum I have a driver okay